في اكونت كوميدي مشهور طبي اسمه جلوكم
فليكن هذه
يحط كل تخصص
ويمثله ويتريق عليه دائما يطلع طبيب
العيون انه مدلل مدلع ومروق
ومع الخادم الشخصي حقه طول الوقت
فهذه الصوره النبطيه المنتشره عنك
طارق المضيان استشاري طب وجراحه العيون
عمليه تصحيح النظر والقرنيه والملعب
الابيض بدايه في التخصص تقريبا فوق يمكن
اربعه اثنين
عشر سنوات او اكثر استشاري من خمس سنوات
[موسيقى]
من الاشياء اللي مثبته صفحه العيون مثلا
النظارات اللي فيها يوفي لايت اللي عايز
الاشعه فوق البنفسجيه نظرات الشمسيه في
الشمس مفيده
فوق بنفسجيه عاليه لها اضرار معينه على
العين على الماده البعيد فالبسه بشكل دوري
كويس شيء ثاني فجوائنا هذه الجافه
والاخبار زي كده قطرات الترطيب مفيد
الواحد رئيس يستمر بترطيب عنب بشكل متكرر
بالنسبه للاطفال لازم له فحوصات روتينيه
على من سنه سنتين وقبل المدرسه
كل من جاي العياده الان يقول انا طول عمري
طول دوامي على الكمبيوتر هم كل واحد حسب
نفسه هو الحاله بينما الكل شغلهم على
الاجهزه
الاجهزه الشتويه لما اقول لك العمليات
تخلي الواحد فات عيونه مع التركيز نفس
الشيء في الاجهزه كل ما ركزت ينقل معدل
الرمز
20 20 كل 20 دقيقه تعمل على الجهاز
ريح عينك 20 ثانيه عن طريق انك تناظر شيء
مدى بعيد او شباك او على الاقل تسكر عيونك
عشان في عضلات داخل فوكس
ترتاح العضلات ويقل الصداع فيه نظاره
وقايه يكون ضد الاشعه ترى الدراسات
العلميه حول هذا الموضوع اثبتت انها ما
منها فائده مجرد شي تسويق دعائي بس
وقرب ومدري ايش ودوائر
واشارات كل هذه غير صحيحه تماما وكلها
مجرد التسويق عشان يسمونك لك بيت عشان
تضغط اللنك وتتحمس والموقع يكسب ااا فلوس
مبالغ ولا ايه ما لها اي فائده علميه مثل
ما ذكرتك الترطيب العين مراجعه الطبيعي
مشكله همم قاده 20 20 الاساسيه اللي ممكن
تكون مفيده العين
الشخص اللي عندنا ضعف النظر يحتاجوا بس
نضاره في الواقع عنده اربع خيارات يعني
الذرات يا عدسات لاصقه وما ينصح فيها
مسموح في المناسبات بس لكن يوميه ما ننسى
فيها او عمليات تصحيح نظر اذا كانت
الفحوصات مناسبه النقطه الاخرى اذا عنده
ضعف قليل ولا يبي يلبس النظاره عادي ترى
لبس النظاره مو ضروري اذا ما لبستها ماتت
ذره ولا تفيد نظرت صف الرؤيه اثناء لبسها
لا لها فائده ولا لحظه اذا كان النظر باسم
البضعف باسم مسؤوله بس النظاره ولا لا
كلامي ما ينطبق على الاطفال دون سن السبعه
دون سن السبع الموضوع مختلف فوق سن السبعه
هذه الاربعه خيارات
[موسيقى]
في حكمه يقول لك لو سكت الجهلاء الاقل
الخلاف يعني المشكله طب شيء حساس جدا يعني
ياما تجينا حالات بالطوارئ
علاج شعبي غير مجرب وغير مدروس ولا حتى
تتاكد منه واحد قال في مجلس ريحان يحطون
بعض النباتات
تؤدي الى ضعف كبير
لو تدري علشان العلاج واحد كم ياخذ في
الطب علشان يصير
قابل للاستعمال في الطب سنين طويله بعض
عشر سنوات علشان بس يقول خلاص هذا امني
يمر التجارب مختبريه بعدين تجارب الله
يكرمكم على الحيوانات بعدين
مسيره طويله اسمها فيزون فيسبوك الى ما
يصير خلاص قبل الاستعمال بس يجيك وحده
مجلس يقول لك معلومه وتسويها غلط
[موسيقى]
ممتاز العمليه
كانت الا بس ما ارتحت لها انا عارف كويس
كت ليه كانت مبتسم كان
فادامه مبتسم اكيد انه يخبي شيء ثاني عنده
غلط
[موسيقى]
اسباب
بكفاءه وذك سلوشن سباي اس تي سي
[موسيقى]
اغلى حاسه عند الانسان النظره
كده يعني من الجوال الخمس نظر الواحد على
طول يخاف انه ينعم للابد احساس مخيف تماما
طبعا طب العيون تخصصات بالنسبه للتخصصي
انا عمليه تصحيح النظر والمال الابيض
والقرنيه اجمل شيء فيها الصراحه وهذا
الشيء الحمد لله الله وفقني له المرضى بعد
العمليات يعني جدا يكونوا مبسوطين اللهم
لك الحمد والشكر هذا الله لا مكانك من
خدمه الناس نعمه عظيمه
الله يعافيكم الله يجزاكم خير ويطول
اعماركم
بالله عليك
اهلا وسهلا
[موسيقى]